there was a song that our school dances
you had to be hands touch one two step
you had to be your arms length away so
tell me about that but when oh so what
do you mean so like in like eighth grade
for our dances there's like chaperones
and you had to be one arm length away
because that was you know social
distancing for when you're horny you
know you try to be one one arm's laying
away semen's the original cove
spreading everywhere dog
but when sierra's one two step or uh
goodies goodies that [ __ ] when that come
on everybody would break the arm barrier
people
that i mean that was like the first time
my brain heard something i was like oh
[ __ ] me
to do who is that guy
i think it's petey pop
i know what it is
wasn't that was that cookies no
goodies goodies clothes but when that
came on that was like the first time my
body really felt something you know i
remember the first porn i ever googled
was boobs.com that was the original but
the second time i really felt something
was when goodies came on at the school
dance and that was big that was
everybody all the chaperones were like
you guys are doing the freak dancing get
them away but yeah they always try to
break it up somebody blow a whistle
turn the lights off the claws yeah they
had air horns yeah exactly
it's like you're lying yeah exactly your
shirt's off you're sweating
yeah that was the first time oh that was
crazy dude school dances man i remember
one time going to pick this girl up oh
oh freak-a-leek was that it freakily was
a uh no goodies is there a song called
goodies goodies
sierra just had jams
yeah just
just uh
no just goodies my good
goodies i think's your goodies
goody sierra oh with petey pablo
yeah i think that that's the same photo
on the nightstand no the second one down
damn look at me
i know my [ __ ] dude
there we go subliminal messaging nelly
is horny or were they dating
probably did they date i wonder i don't
know
yeah i don't think we can play it anyway
can we
okay yeah regardless i'm playing in my
mind a little bit right now but that's
yeah
but right that was like the school dance
stuff was uh
this was even who'd you go with
i think you just went with homies
[Laughter]
but
like 8th grade dance you kind of just
showed up and then you just kind of like
like in movies you'd sit at the wall and
you'd wait to make eye contact with but
in high school that's when you would ask
the girl
oh really we had no i went on our school
it was big you had to get asked or ask
at like 7th grade wow and they had
different dances man they had sadie
hawkins city hawkins okay then they had
this one dance where they made a big
shirt yeah they would sew the shirt
sleeves together it was like what was it
called parachute love lock or something
you see how many people you could fit in
there no you had it was you and your
date so y'all were like a big circle you
know by the sleeves yeah yeah and so you
were
this um have been spring fling or
something said they would have these
special shirts made for everybody and
you had to be like locked in like this
yeah so all night you were kind of
locked in how did you pee uh
your pants you just commit
that'd be a weird place to get it
and then she's going out the honorable
one oh yeah yeah no i uh i remember one
year i asked a girl uh
to homecoming in a tiffany's box but it
just said uh homecoming on on a piece of
paper and then i opened it like i was
proposing and then she friend zoned me
that night i went in for the kiss and
she gave me the cheese
hit me with the cheek i mean yeah i was
way out of my league this girl she she
was like the girl who had like the the
tits in town
she was like she was oh you asked
anybody both of them yeah you guys see
anybody about uh in camera california
about uh about christina i mean she had
the bags on her
were fully charged but byron
yeah i loved it
yeah but she was awesome and but i was
like i was really stepping outside of my
bushes you know oh dude i remember this
one girl man i think her name was noel
right good titty name and she had
i don't know her whole body was tits
yeah her whole body was just made out of
tit dude every part of her body was hit
you graze her hand a little bit you're
like oh [ __ ] oh
areola even a high five felt like it had
milk in it you know what i was saying
she just was all dead yeah
and i remember somehow
he agreed to go to a dance with me i
i even remember when i asked her i was
so i was on mushrooms when i asked her
and i got so hyped after he said yes i
ran and jumped over a chain-link fence
and cut my
literally cut my hand open it and my
stomach opened did you grip it like you
were pole vaulting a little bit no i
just tried to jump up completely
straight into it oh it's so stoked oh
cause you're on mushrooms yeah i was
like i'm gonna show her this cool trick
you know what i'm saying she knows she's
dealing with a savage name and that was
tet girl
so anyway i healed up and we went to the
dance
and uh and one of my hands was still
pretty bandaged up you know my hand
where i gotten cut pretty well was
pretty abandoned
so i remember she let me like kind of
get one of those tits out boy and i'm
just batting that thing around like
mayweather [ __ ] just throwing rice on it
oh it looks definitely that's what'll
heal the hand oh it was some you know
yeah some canelo bro yeah yeah
right just a little little batting
practice with that t-top oh yeah and um
and then later on at night she like
we're at my friend's house and we're
sitting there and they had a pool table
and i'm like trying to get like trying
to get her underpants off a little with
the mitt on oh it was so hard and i
think she kept thought uh
that i was like tapping her on the [ __ ]
like i was trying to ask her a question
yeah yeah cause she would i could see
that like what you know because i kept
every time i'd like kind of touch her
yeah you should have had her like
seductively like undo the wrap on your
hand with her teeth or something going
around like if going back in time dude i
would do it so different but i got so
nervous because she was so she was the
hot she was the she was just a living
tit
and i got so nervous that i just kind of
i just fell apart and
uh
how's she doing now
i'm sure she's beautiful and has a
family same to it like most of the
people that i know or most of the you
know like most women that i stalk
occasionally at night on facebook
every once in a while your dad will see
how they're doing for kids arkansas
yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one